PROFESSOR: So now,
let me make the first
of our technical asides, which
you can skip over if you're not
interested in the
mathematical details
or for those of you that
have a higher-level,
say, upper-level-undergraduate
or even graduate-level
understanding of transport
phenomena and fluid mechanics.
I'd like to show you some
of the equations that
are behind the
results that I've been
quoting in all the lectures.
So in particular, let's
derive the Wells curve.
So part of that was a
theory of drop settling.
Here, I will quote
a certain result,
because the derivation
would be a lot longer.
Actually, for that, you could
refer to my online class 10.50x,
which is that if you have
a droplet or a particle
of a radius R and it is
settling under gravity--
so it has a mass m, and the
gravitational force is m g,
where g is the
gravitational acceleration--
then there is a flow of
fluid around this object.
And relative to
the moving object,
the flow is going the other way.
And if you solve
for the viscous flow
around an object being
dragged through a fluid,
then you arrive at the
result of Stokes, which
is the drag on that fluid.
So if you're falling
at a velocity v,
then the drag
force is -- f_d is -- 6*pi
times the radius of the
drop times the viscosity
of the fluid times the
velocity of the drop.
So we're falling
at a velocity v,
which is the settling velocity.
And this here is the
Stokes drag coefficient,
which comes from solving the
fluid mechanics of viscous flow
around a sphere translating
at a constant speed.
We can, furthermore, say that the
mass of the droplet, of course,
is 4*pi/3 times the density
of the droplet liquid, times
the radius cubed.
And so given the
mass of the droplet,
there's a force balance
between the gravitational force
m g and the drag force when the
particle reaches a terminal
velocity.
So if we think of this v_s as
the terminal velocity where
it's accelerating until there's
a balance between the forces
and is moving at a speed, it's
given by this force balance.
And from that
equation, we can solve
for the settling velocity, which
is energy divided by 6*pi*R.
And to use the same
notation as before,
I'll call this mu_a -- the
air -- but generally, it's
the viscosity of
the ambient fluid
around the particle
as it's settling.
And if we plug in the value
for m g, so that's 4/3*pi*rho*g*
R^3 over 6*pi*R*rho_a.
And so we simplify
that, we end up
with (2/9)*rho*g*r^2/mu_a.
So that's the settling speed.
And this is a pretty
important concept,
so I'll just sketch it here.
So if we want to know
what's the settling
speed as a function of
the radius of the drop,
then you see it
grows like R^2.
So it's like this.
And then to put a scale on
that, if we have a particle that
is 3 microns -- so that's
really an aerosol particle --
then the settling speed
is around 1 millimeter
a second if we use
the density of water
and the viscosity of
air for this formula.
And so that's already a
fairly slow settling speed,
millimeter per second.
So you can already
see the particles that
are in the micron
range will be suspended
in the air for a
long period of time,
as long as they
don't evaporate away.
And so that is now the second
part of the calculation.
Oh, and I should the
finish the first part here.
What we're left with is that
the settling time is L over v_s.
And that's the formula
that we had before,
which is 9*mu_a*L divided
by 2*rho*g*r^2.
So this is our first
part of the Wells curve.
So if I draw the
Wells curve over here
in the traditional way, where
I plot on the horizontal
axis the size of the particle,
and in a downward axis,
we draw the time, then we have
a curve like this for settling.
And the reason it's drawn
down, I guess maybe the feeling
that as you're sort of falling
down a particle a certain size,
you hit this curve and that's
when you've settled a distance
L and fallen out of the air.
So now, let's look
at evaporation,
which is our second topic.
I've lost my blue [marker] -- here it is.
So these droplets are
getting very small
as they're evaporating,
and it's happening very quickly,
as we shall show in a moment.
And so a natural assumption
is that the process
is limited by the
diffusion of water vapor
away from the droplet,
because essentially we
have this little droplet
here with a certain size
R, which is now going
to be varying with time.
So it has a radius R(t).
And it's really
close to the surface.
There is an equilibrium
concentration --
we'll call it c_w --
of water, which depends
on the temperature.
So that's kind of the
saturation concentration
of water vapor in the air.
But then, if the water is
going to evaporate more,
it would create more
concentration, which would then
re-condense on the particle.
So in order for it to
continue evaporating,
that water vapor that is
produced has to diffuse away.
So there's going to be a
gradient of water vapor going
outwards from c_w -- [it] is the
concentration at position R.
And then far away, there is
a sort of diffusion layer
thickness, delta.
And far beyond the
diffusion layer thickness,
the concentration is going
to approach the equilibrium
concentration in
the ambient air.
c at infinity is going to be
c_w times the relative humidity.
So that's the ratio of
the concentration of water
vapor in the air to the
saturation concentration,
c_w, by definition.
Now, the math
problem that we have
to solve for this diffusion
problem -- with a moving boundary
in this case, though we'll
assume it's pseudosteady --
is dc/dt is the diffusion
coefficient of water
times the Laplacian
of c, so just
the diffusion equation with
these two boundary conditions.
Now, an interesting aspect a
three-dimensional spherical
diffusion is that at first
the diffusion layer grows,
but it very quickly
reaches a steady state.
And if we assume that
that diffusion time
to reach this distance
delta is fast,
so they reach a
steady state, so it's
a kind of quasisteady or
pseudosteady shrinking
of the droplet with sort of
a diffusion layer around it
that's always kind of
at the steady value,
then it turns out that
this diffusion layer
is on the order of the
particle size.
So as the particle shrinks, the
diffusion layer also shrinks.
But it has a
well-defined thickness,
as opposed to
diffusion in one or two
dimensions, where the
diffusion layer just
keeps growing out to infinity.
For example, like
square root of time --
you don't reach a steady
state in an infinite domain.
So the bottom line
of this calculation,
which I will not go
through right now,
is that the flux of
water on the surface
is the area of the surface at a
given moment, where the size is
R, times essentially
Fick's law, where
the driving force, the
change in concentration
from the surface to
the bulk, is c_w times
one minus relative humidity,
the diffusivity of water,
and then divided by delta,
the diffusion layer thickness.
And it turns out that with
these coefficients here,
it turns out to be exactly R.
So this is not a scaling
result, but actually
an exact result for pseudo
steady spherical diffusion
of water vapor.
So now, we have the
flux on the surface.
It's uniform on the surface.
And it's [assumed]
to be pseudosteady.
And so then I can write
down that the change
in the size of the water
droplet volume, which
is (4*pi/3)*R^3
is equal to minus
the volume of a water molecule
times the flux of water.
So that's basically my volume
or mass balance of water.
So if I plug this in here,
then I get dR/dt is equal to --
let's see, collecting
all the terms here --
so derivative of R^3
is 3*R^2.
So the 3's cancel.
And then I have
a 4*pi*R^2,
which cancels this
4*pi*R^2.
So I just have dR/dt is
-v_w*D_w*c_w*(1-RH)/R.
If I put this R on the other
side here, then I have --
I'll just continue
the derivation here --
I have R dR/dt is equal
to all this stuff.
So -v_w*D_w*c_w*(1-RH).
And then this
expression here can
be written as 1/2 the
derivative of R^2.
So what we find is that R^2
is linear in time.
And then using the boundary
condition that we start out
at a certain initial
value, R_0, then I'm
going to get the R(t) is
the initial value R_0 times
the square root of 1 minus
t over a certain evaporation
time.
And that evaporation
time is given here
by (R_0)^2 times basically
all these coefficients here,
where I'll separate out
the effective humidity,
and then a bunch of other
coefficients, which you can see
have units of length
squared over time,
because R_0 is a length squared.
So it's effectively some
kind of diffusivity.
And what we get from
this calculation
is that this
effective diffusivity
that goes into this
expression is -- there's
a factor 2 from this guy --
there's a 2*v_w*D_w*c_w.
And if you plug in
values for water vapor,
for the saturation pressure,
and the diffusivity,
and the volume of water in
air, then this coefficient
turns out to be 1.2e-9
meters squared
for second for pure water.
And that's where you get now
the second part of the Wells
theory, which is the
evaporation, which gives you
a curve looking like this.
So that there's this
sort of in this theory
a natural crossover between
large drops, which in this case
here are ones that are
large enough to settle out
of the fluid before
they evaporate,
and small drops,
which evaporate.
On the other hand, for
true biological fluids
that appear in
respiratory droplets,
the evaporation is limited
by solutes and salts, which
stop the evaporation
and, in fact,
can attract even more
water in some cases.
So that the evaporation part
of it is not as accurate,
and we tend to see that
the settling part is more
important to consider, given
an equilibrium distribution
of droplets that
has been measured
and is understood to come from
different types of respiration.